[Music]  how could you let Balthasar brats just  get away you're fired  he really good to snuggle with Agnes  what are you doing since you don't have  a job I just wanted to help  ah excuse me oh hey could you oh of  course  now as I was saying hi good my seriously  Wow I really must have a word with you  on behalf of your twin brother drew why  twin brother hey brother do that I can't  thank me  [Music]  doesn't love this guy  look at him Oh his hair would make you  better look at this face are you so mad  you must see the beautiful wife oh sweet  talker this place is amazing it's nice  like gasp you're I'm not really  interesting  Masek groovy losing blood broken boobs  you ready to continue the family  tradition you and me no I left that life  behind me just one  [Music]  I'm going in okay  this does not mean that we are going  back to heist music